[Music]
opposed to make you smile you're goddamn
I'm not mountain top speed through all
the trials you are the here
[Music]
[Music]
running through a thunderstorm
[Music]
electrified stasis up and whack good
climber
[Music]
[Applause]
I win striker here found a secret
minigame in a Taino village
it's called flying for apples
little-known fact
Lionel's are big fans of hide and seek
[Laughter]
the only problem is they're very
competitive shrines with motion puzzles
definitely bring their fair share of
frustration but I think it's safe to say
that add relic here found the puzzle
extremely frustrating does your master
cycle keep running out of gas
well how about some fossil fuel okay
ladies and gentlemen it's now time for
the Eagle clan spin it boys
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's never too late to start come on mom
and dad let's toss the old stalling
around you know what they say if you
fail just try try the bunny slopes first
this horse doesn't have a bug but a
fever disco
[Music]
knock-knock get in I'm home well on the
bright side it's not raining
[Applause]
[Music]
you've got Gibson red post to make you
smile snowball down that mountain top
speed through all the trials you are the
hero
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]